hi there my name is Ryan route I'm a
post-doctoral fellow at the Allen
Institute in the University of
Washington Seattle I'm really excited to
talk to you today about our recent work
which you can find at this link here and
which involves this awesome team of
collaborators entitled arousal as a
universal embedding for spatiotemporal
brain Dynamics now a goal of this work
really is to unify a few different
Pockets or sectors of Neuroscience and
to do so using tools from dynamical
systems theory and machine learning and
that's kind of a lot so I'm going to
give a really streamlined uh kind of
overview of this work in this talk and
I'd really encourage you if you're
interested to check out the paper and
also the references throughout that
paper that really give you a picture of
how this story has unfolded across these
different areas of
Neuroscience so let's Jump Right In um
what I'm showing you right here is
ongoing brain activity uh recorded from
an awake Mouse now you can imagine just
kind of looking down and this is all
measured at the surface of the brain and
what you see is actually very typical of
what you see also in the human brain in
Mamon brains in general vertebrae brains
even invertebrate brains you find these
in the awake state even you find these
ongoing spontaneous patterns of large
scale brain activity involving the
coordinated uh behavior of thousands
even millions of cells
and naturally we want to know where's
all this activity coming from right uh
is is the mouse looking at things is it
does it depend on what the mouse is
thinking about um what are all these
different brain regions always saying to
each other right now the key idea that
we're trying to put forth in this work
and what I'm going to try to elaborate
on in this talk is that
ultimately this might be a lot simpler a
lot of what we see up here may
ultimately be reflection
or manifestations of some underlying
intrinsic regulatory process for the
brain that's continuously regulating
brainwide physiology not only that but
it's also regulating brainwide
physiology in relation to organism wide
uh physiology and behavior of the
organism so kind of synchronizing
everything into a continuous
flow now I'll get into how we actually
might test a hypothesis motivated from
this perspective But ultimately where
this is going to take us is to this idea
that in
theory if this is on the right track
then all I would need is some other
measurement from the organism that is
coupled to this process that we're
hypothesizing is indeed Global um and in
theory that measurement should carry
enough information to basically know
what's going on in this brainwide
activity and we're going to actually do
this using something to simple as pupil
diameter so just that little black dot
in your eye might have this as well and
it's continuously fluctuating up and
down and what we're going to show is
that that carries actually enough
information to be able to get pretty
good reconstructions of this large scale
brain activity that you see across the
mouse brain now before we get to that uh
we're just going to back up and I'll
give a little overview of brain Dynamics
in general I know a lot of people
interested in dynamical systems theory
uh watch this Channel and so um the
upshot really is that I believe that
this perspective is very valid very
useful for looking and thinking looking
at organisms and thinking about their
brain activity so organisms and their
brains are intrinsically Dynamic and
they really pose a challenge when we go
towards modeling these dynamical systems
for the usual reasons right they are
very high-dimensional um a a really uh
limiting challenge that we have in
biology and Neuroscience is that we can
only measure a tiny subset of the
degrees of freedom of the system uh
either a particular space or temporal
scale or just you know a few of the
relevant biological elements cells Etc
um and hidden in all those unmeasured
scales that are a lot of feedback
interactions nonlinearity circular
causality right so we can only access a
any subset of of those variables at one
time and there's a lot of craziness
happening in the background and so you
might think okay well what do we do now
right this seems like an impossible task
but I think Nature has given us a path
forward and that is to realize at the
end of the day organisms work right
brains work somehow in spite of all this
and so what that means to me I think is
that this High dimensional configuration
space of the organism you know instead
of exploring all of that instead of
every cell doing its own thing right
there's some low dimensional behavior um
that the system exhibits right there's
some level coordination pieces working
together and so I think as a scientist
as a modeler our goal can then become or
at least my goal is to uncover those
intrinsic
constraints and use them to our
advantage to relate the high dimensional
data and observations that we are met
with relate those to some underlying
organism intrinsic low-dimensional
processes right and the starting point
for this is going to be what I'm
referring to as arousal what different
fields have referred to as arousal uh
going through Neuroscience biology
psychology ethology um and uh you can
think of this as basically from the
datadriven perspective principal
component number one um and and that
kind of shows up in all of our different
measurements as really a dominant
component especially on this time scale
of seconds so what I'm showing you here
is a a very beautiful paper and very
wellknown especially in Neuroscience uh
from a few years back that basically
showed that in an awake Mouse on the
time scale seconds you have these
ongoing fluctuations that are
coordinated Across The Locomotion uh
behavior of the animal pupil diameter
whisking Behavior this is a mouse um all
of these are tightly linked to ongoing
fluctuations in population level neural
activity so again thousands of neurons
all kind of doing behaving in this
coordinated fashion in relation to
behavior um but it's not just this set
of observables okay in different pockets
of Neuroscience you also see uh that so
for example over here that the ionic
environment that these neurons are
bathed in properties the chemical
composition of that environment is
constantly continuous ly changing on
this time scale of seconds uh you also
see this for different cell types in the
brain like astrocytes and the metabolic
properties of the brain again all
fluctuating on this time scale seconds
and these these fluctuations occur even
at the early stages of sensory input so
even at the level of the retina already
you're starting to see information
coming from the world uh being shaped
according to these ongoing fluctuations
and
arousal but what exactly is arousal
right we can see that it's probably
important to get a handle on this as
it's popping up everywhere but it's kind
of abstract at this stage and we don't
really know how to study it so to make
things concrete um how we're going to
study it in in this work here is we're
going to start off with a a typical set
of measurements so here this is an awake
Mouse and we measured something like pup
diameter uh whisker be whisker motion of
the animal and then brain activity these
are just a couple example time traces
and what you can see here right away is
you see these coordinated fluctuations
across these different time series and
naturally one way to interpret this
might be to say okay every time the
mouse whisks right it's causing these
changes in pupil diameter it's causing
these changes in brain activity that
leaves un addressed this question of
what's actually causing the mouse to
whisk in the first place right what's
causing the mouse to move its whiskers
in the first place and again it's if we
if we try to interpret specific causal
interactions between these variables we
tend to leave out uh what I was showing
on the previous slide which is all these
other variables that are ultimately
coupled to what we've been calling
arousal so the tech we're going to take
instead in this study and the
perspective we're putting forth is the
idea that this ultimately originates
from some underlying process intrinsic
to the organism so there are some
intrinsic laws of motion that keep keep
this so-called arousal process uh
continuing to fluct fluctuate on the
time scale of seconds even as you're
listening to this talk right now
hopefully or on and off uh and as I'm
talking right now you have these ongoing
fluctuations and the ideas is to treat
these as simply measurements of this
underlying process they're all just
related to this underlying arousal
process via some functions that we might
be able to learn from data okay and so
over here we have this organism
intrinsic manifold uh this low
dimensional structure on which these
arousal trajectories unfold and you have
stochastic perturbations from inside and
outside the
organism but uh so now to actually work
with this kind of data and to test
hypothesis we teamed up with these
awesome
experimentalists uh right here from
Washington University in St Louis and
what we're going to do is to measure
simultaneously uh large scale brain
activity and whisker motion and uh and
pupil diameter and ultimately we're
going to try to you know from data go
map back to this hypothesize underlying
process can we link these things back to
an underlying process so to set up this
problem again we're going to start with
this idea that you have some underlying
process that we do not observe and we
have access to through some some
idealized observation functions we have
access to pupil diameter over here and
down there we have brainwide activity or
large scale cortex wide activity
technically um and our goal is going to
be to relate these two via some common
state some common process so this
diagram will be familiar to a lot of
people here this idea of an encoder and
a decoder and a latent space in the
middle that really contains information
about both of these things right so this
is the type of thing that should be
imposs should be possible if we're on
the right track um but there's a catch
here which is uh well first of all
before I get into that let's talk about
why we might actually think that we have
brainwide activity large scale brain
activity coupled to this process now
this goes back to a paper from a couple
years ago uh where we looked at this is
now humans U and and we found that
ongoing fluctuations and arousal of the
kind I've been describing so far uh so
measured with pupil diameter breathing
rate this sort of thing are coupled to
these large scale traveling waves that
move throughout the cerebral cortex and
are topographically parallel to or you
know respect the functional Anatomy that
we know about in a way that matches what
we see going on in the thalamus in the
striatum in the cerebellum so all these
major pieces of the brain have these
synchronized traveling waves that are
flowing in synchrony with ongoing
fluctuations and arousal
so okay so this is why we were expecting
in the mouse that ultimately large scale
brain activity can be thought of as
simply another manifestation another
reflection another function of this
underlying
process but we still have this challenge
of how do we actually go from a scalar
variable over here scalar observable to
a high-dimensional observable over there
right and how we're going to do that now
is we're going to uh take motivation
take inspiration from toin theorem from
uh dynamical systems theory and what's
been referred to as a time delay
embedding uh as the strategy that we're
actually going to use here so we're
going to
take so basically so we're going to go
to this toy system this Loren system uh
a popular toy nonlinear dynamical system
simple model for chaos and it involves
these three state variables XY Z who
interact with one another through some
governing some known governing equations
some deterministic equations okay and so
it traces out these trajectories over
time Etc and let's say that we have that
we access two measurements from the
system and they're just going to be the
state variables X and Y so these are two
scalers measured from this
three-dimensional system and ideally we
are going to be able to say something
we'd like to be able to say something
about the system from which these
variables came from right so we want to
be able to say that they came from the
same system that the system has these
properties there three dimensions
Etc and so the question is how do you
actually go about doing that it turns
out that because let's start over let's
start with X for now because the motion
of X the time evolution of X is entirely
determined by the interaction between X
and the other variables in the system Y
and Z that are all related through this
known governing
equation it turns out that X and the
time history of X are sufficient to
encode that information and basically
reconstruct the underlying attractor
from which it came so here what I'm
showing you is X plotted against a
couple different lagged versions of
itself and you see that basically you
end up with a structure that looks quite
similar to the original one now it looks
kind of stretched and warped in
different ways
and so the geometry is not necessarily
preserved But ultimately the topological
information from the original
three-dimensional attractor is preserved
in this reconstruction what's been
referred to as a shadow manifold uh for
the original system and you can do the
same thing with Y over here um and
ultimately you end up with these
different embeding different views of
really the same system that can be
interrelated through different Maps
different functions uh technically these
are dimorphisms um but basically um to
make this come alive a bit I guess to
get this point across so you can imagine
you have this state unfolding down here
with this Green Dot and the idea is that
this
motion can be viewed in different ways
right you can have a Time series
snapshot of it over here A Time series
over here and you have the the motion in
the delay embedded spaces for X and Y
over there the idea is that these are
all just representations different
representations of the same underlying
process there's one process going on
here okay and that's exactly the
perspective that we're trying to take
with us when we approach the brain
activity the idea that ultimately you
have one arousal process going on and
the evolution the time evolution of this
process we are observing that in the
pupil diameter in the large scale brain
activity in order to test this
hypothesis we're going to talk time
delay embed our pupil
diameter uh into this high-dimensional
delay space that theoretically uncovers
this missing information the information
that we lost when we went from this
arousal manifold to this uh scalar
measurement pupil diameter and once we
have that recovered that information we
can probably collapse this down bit more
to some some low-dimensional manifold
that preserves everything we need from
this hypothesized arousal
manifold and I ideally we can learn a
mapping from that space A Time invariant
mapping now that we've unfolded that
attractor in the space time and variant
mapping that says for each point in
time as a function of my position on
this arousal manifold what does my brain
activity look like at that point in time
as measured through this Widefield
Optical Imaging that we have over here
so now that we've set all this all this
up we can go back to what we set up at
the start of the talk which is this
video showing on the left the original
brain data and on the right this is a
prediction in heldout data um where
we're using the pupil diameter in that
heldout data and we're using our
mappings that we learned in the training
data to predict or reconstruct what
brain activity should look like at each
point in time so I'll let this play out
a little bit and you'll notice that okay
they're not perfect mirror images of one
another but I think the take-home Point
what I'm hoping to convince you of um is
that it becomes hard to really think
about what's going on over here as
something entirely different uh from
what we see over there which is
ultimately all information that is just
contained within ongoing fluctuations in
pupil diameter okay so the goal of this
talk isn't just to basically say that
you can do this but to give us an
explanation for why we are able to do
this and to to give some background for
how we arrived at this
prediction so you know if we look to
quantify this I'll just go through this
part of the talk pretty quickly um we do
quite well in fact even with linear
aggression and just pupil diameter with
no delay embedding um and that's because
that first principal component explains
a lot of the data that we see a lot of
the variants um but the key point is
that the delay embedding and the
nonlinearities allow us to capture that
kind of continuous flow of the
spatiotemporal Dynamics that we see
activity and this is also kind of
clarified with the mean subtracted data
where you're taking out uh basically
that proportion of the variance that
just kind of represents going up and
down in activity um and we see that if
you take that out you're still
explaining quite a lot of the variance
in this data uh the spatially specific
information that's not globally
represented
so uh I'll show this real quick just to
build some intuition for how we're
thinking about this and what the data
looks like um so another way to think
about this is each point in time you can
say you can assign them you do some
clustering and say Hey you look kind of
like this brain state right this spatial
pattern you can go through and do that
for the entire set of image frames and
you can visualize now the entire brain
recording as a trajectory in this
three-dimensional space um and now the
axes are defined in terms of the leading
principal components of the brain
activity and what you can see is that
different colors cluster to different
spots on this manifold of this this
state space right and so the idea is
that you have a characteristic flow
characteristic Dynamic that goes through
these different
states now if we take those same colors
and plot them on a trajectory that's
reconstructed in the delay coordinates
from pupil diameter we see that once
again in fact the colors segregate out
to different spots on of the state space
so what this is getting at is that this
spatially specific information
represented by the segregation of colors
along this state space where colors
corespond to different brain maps that
information is actually you know a lot
of this is basically there already in
pupil diameter the pupil Dynamics kind
of uh recapitulate the spatially
specific
information so finally uh we'll take
this out to a big picture Okay this was
a spefic specific prediction about
Widefield calcium measure measurements
and that we should be able to
reconstruct those but we have this
intermediate uh thing that we've
constructed the so-called arousal
manifold which is intrinsic to the
organism right so it's not dependent on
any observation space and this is really
where uh we start thinking about this
idea of a universal embedding in how we
might be able to put together these
different pieces of the organism that we
typically study in bi biology and
Neuroscience uh independently of one
another so here's kind of the big uh
summary picture so you have something
like this this idealized arousal
manifold here I'm just parameterizing it
according to two coordinates call it Z1
and Z2 and the idea is that you have
some basic flow on this manifold so this
is kind of this a canonical cycle if you
will of the arousal Dynamics this a
vector field telling you how you move
how you tend to move on this
manifold you can also learn functions
that take you to observables so again
these are recorded at Washington
University in St Louis we have the
Widefield calcium images that tell us
basically on average what to expect at
each piece of this manifold what do what
does the Widefield calcium look like on
average what can I expect to see there
but now we can go go through and use
neural networks or use linear regression
use whatever else to basically learn
functions that take us to different
measurements um from this same latent
manifold so recorded simultaneously
simultaneously with the calcium
measurements were uh measurements of
approximating oxidative metabolism in
the brain of blood flow
hemodynamics and so we can kind of plot
those on the same space and say hey for
each spot on the manifold what can I
expect to look like from each of these
different observations and then of
course we can throw in here the scaler
observables pupil diameter and whisker
movement now a key point is that while
these were all recorded simultaneously
the idea is if we have this organism
intrinsic manifold we can now go and use
this to get kind of a group level or a a
uh averaged picture of what this tends
to look like across mice even using
observables that recorded a separately
in different sessions different data
sets different experiments um so now
what we're going to do is turn to the
Allen brain Institute uh who has
released publicly available data really
exceptional data using a set of
modalities that is very complimentary to
what was recorded in this data set over
here and so behavioral variables
physiological variables like pupil
diameter and running speed uh we can do
the play the same game over there using
functions that we've learned in that
data um and we plot them on the same
manifold using transfer learning uh
which uh I guess is is discussed a bit
more in the paper but uh the key point
is you can go through and now do this
for another you know more observables
basically that have served as the basis
for entire sectors of Neuroscience a lot
of amazing work looking at different in
this case uh phenomena related to the
state of the
hippocampus uh measurements of uh
basically other electrophysiological
measurements of the brain activity we
can start to think about all of these
things as resulting from functions of
this unified process so in some you have
this you have three things you have this
latent manifold you have function taking
you to the flow along this manifold and
then you have observation functions that
take you to uh an expectation of what
that looks like from the perspective of
each of these
measurements so in some uh
preprint is available at this link um
and the real take-home Point here is
that when we see these amazing spaer
temporal patterns of brain activity the
idea we're putting forth here is that
ultimately this might come down to a
manifestation reflections of some
underlying organism wide process that is
regulating uh everything going on in the
organism and is not not actually
specific to the brain activity so
funding sources are listed over there uh
and you know big thank you to the groups
that made this work possible in
particular the Shanahan Family
Foundation uh and Allen Institute just
funded a lot of uh me being able to do
this work so uh please reach out email
address is over there uh if you have any
questions would like to chat more any
complaints I'd love to hear from you so
thanks so much for
watching